40 full seconds of logos from 20th
Century Fox and Friends including a
multi era double low going right off the
top if you think singing is gonna make
me overlook excessive logo action you've
got another thing coming
19th century dabbing ladies and gents
this is the moonship way to fool the end
of the movie there's no way those
jugglers in the back were mid juggle of
that many rings in a completely dark
room so the wire considering this is
revealed to be a young Barnum
daydreaming it's pretty impressive that
he correctly dreamt up the exact people
he would later enslave I mean exploit I
mean hire to be in his show you your
circus may be utterly transcendent that
doesn't give the viewer any vitamin A or
riboflavin her excellent spit-take has
drenched the front of her dress here but
by the time she gets to her father it's
completely dry how does that fire anyway
how would you get out no kidding but
more importantly how did you know to
meet here our picturesque Oceanside
bluffs just magnets for children
destined for storybook relationships
even the flashbacks are singing that
feels like home you climbed an overgrown
fence to look through fog got a house
built 200 years ago and somehow bad
feels like home this is the most tough
animated kid friendship ever put to film
since I guess the Fox and the Hound we
can live in the world that we
then why to sell this point did you
design what looks like poison ivy is
abandoned workshop ecstasy that
particular light making that Lian shadow
is about as likely as my shadow looking
like Chris Hemsworth also literal
foreshadowing separated at youth look
I'd let this relationship mean something
if it were taking place later in life at
elementary school-age boys and girls
aren't making lifelong relationships
they're watching cartoons and thinking
about cooties
the notebook the song he literally goes
for his father's funeral - stealing
bread and might even be the same day
also how does a young PT not know that
you don't run until your spotter if he
grabs his bread nonchalantly he may have
gotten away with it reversed
pickpocketing also how the does he
know where she lives
and if he's dropping mail into the bag
of the girl's mail carrier and is in the
same city in neighborhood why not go
visit
[Music]
[Applause]
dreams is shouldn't that fancy finishing
school have taught her about subject
verb agreement and after nine minutes of
super sympathetic flashback memories
movie hopes you can finally be happy for
PT Barnum because he's young and in love
like you were once even though you
didn't turn out later to be a racist
abusive manipulative asshole I mean you
probably didn't soon tire of your life
of having nothing tell that to Cleveland
Browns fans this song feels like it's
been going on for about ten months
here's a sin for the candling the
out of this scene bull with all the
candles
Bruce was at his all mightiest in
providing the moon for this rooftop
number little-known fact
thousands of young lovers die every year
when their partners fail to catch them
at the last second during romantic
rooftop musical numbers holy that song
made her pregnant PT's pencil led breaks
and he gets all flustered by it instead
of picking up one of these spare pencils
in the middle cup on his desk and just
continuing he even goes to sharpen that
dead pencil rather than switched to a
new one my point is the real PT Barnum
was a racist abusive son-of-a-bitch what
do you call those two girls honestly
regret numbers one and two i legit don't
even remember their names like just see
regret oh look he invented the rave
Jesus in Christ even a movie mocking a
musical that over uses a theme song
wouldn't use the theme song as often as
this non parody movie does what are you
looking at flop doodle doodle there was
no way that was ever an actual insult
you louse a gobbler in the South China
Seas so you lied about ships that you
stole from your employer to defraud a
bank to give you a loan
oh you rapscallion you see you not see
that elephant until just now
it's literally five feet away so she's
planning to buy eggs bread onions a
lemon flour and potatoes four and
guessing at least a week if not longer
that is a high-carb low-protein diet has
a decent breakfast in those ingredients
but all the other meals are gonna suck I
realized they're poor right now and
that's actually the point of showing us
this grocery list but if she's got money
for groceries I think she could stretch
it further than she has here I mean I
hear Big Top Ramen is cheapest I am
putting together a show and I need a
star
the real Barnum's first star was an 80
year old black woman he claimed was 160
years old and was George Washington's
nurse and when she died he charged four
tickets to see her autopsy wonder why I
didn't make the movie
put a laughing well I'm not laughing
anyway kids who might as well get paid
this is the fictional nice version of PT
Barnum this movie came up with and even
he's an opportunistic asshole they won't
laugh
they'll salute he just basically
admitted people would laugh at this guy
now he's saying this and because it's a
movie this flip flop is gonna work is it
time for the upbeat and fun finding
people Barnum can exploit montage let's
do it
how's the looking girls is one of his
daughters right-handed and one
left-handed or did you cheat on that in
order to symmetrically frame the shot
with their arms pretty sure I know the
answer so here's a set Teen Wolf
Slender Man fatter Jon Lovitz Glenn
Close after his perm Daniel de Dracula
Lucy who tattooed Colonel Mustard Keaton
lands on a leg and put us on stage Owen
County on an entertainer that leverages
the controversial nature of their work
for their own gain I want to be against
it my business model depends on me being
for though I certainly can understand
the excitement of someone you will
eventually name dog boy jumping up on
your desk the high-five wasn't actually
invented until the 1970s that guy is 500
pounds the way asa butterfield is 300
roughly 10% of this movie is footage of
poster reveals dog boy milk
get your dog boy milk here everyone
loves drinking milk named after a dog
boy so you have the guy you described as
a very good thief taking tickets and
handling all your money the savvy
business acumen with his Barnum guy just
never stops he could catch it oh oh Hugh
Jackman wanted to stern another musical
and instead of filming something like
The Music Man remake seriously picture
Hugh Jackman as Henry Hill and tell me
it's not goddamn perfect they made this
real-life O'Hare from the Lorax here
joins every other performer in not only
being a freak that Barnum can exploit
but also somehow an incredible singer
none of this was rehearsed fYI I know
they expanded quickly they even have a
physical ring now and an offstage
dancing bear as well my point is that
the passage of time is something this
movie cares a little about and cares
even less about how much you care about
it due to this ovation Barnum mistakenly
believes people love freak shows when in
reality they just love well
choreographed choral performances does
it bother you that everything you're
selling is fake critic as the villain
cliche also is it a problem in your
movie when the main antagonist is
actually the one who makes the most
sense theater critic you can't find joy
in the theater now who's a fraud still
you Barnum still you movie waits 34
minutes before even trying to Efron play
big good money to watch people stand
around at all for two hours and they
call me a con man
I can't even with this bullsh did Barnum
truly must understand entertainment this
grossly could he have been successful at
all if he was this misguided about the
habits of the everyman
while mr. and mrs. Barnum argue about
how to cure their daughters bullying
problem it's worth pointing out how
sinfully oversized this bedroom is and
also how sinfully overlit it is handle
much room you understand this just
associating with you could cost me my
inheritance then why are you here you
knew who he was when you agreed to come
to this public bar and share several
drinks with him it's line of dialogue is
pure gibberish filler bulls right here
right now I put the uh friend I never
knew how much I needed a musical version
of shark tank until right now
you gotta play the irony here is that
he's suavely winning over a member of
the rich elite because he feels
inadequate in dealing with the rich
elite and it's a marketing manager to
help sell his circus to the rich elite
the likes of which he is currently
selling to perfectly this barroom
choreography between the bartender
Jackman and Zachman is genuinely
impressive and magnetic but considering
that both just down at least seven shots
within four minutes I'm pretty sure
they'd barely be standing up at this
point let alone pulling off these moves
you'd better come see this you'd better
come see this cliche all the snobs in
New York read he does it thinking for
them this creator bitching about a
critic seems overly sensitive and unable
to just enjoy his creative freedom I
guess I'll just have to tell the Queen
that either all of us go well none of us
will remember this is the 1860s but
here's rich white Zac Efron's character
champion racial equality because he fell
in love miss Lynd let me get to the
point I'd like to bring it to New York
and if you agree on making the most
famous singer not in Europe but in the
entire world wasn't his show about
curiosities he's lost sight of his
original vision is what I'm saying and
now he's just another everyday producer
and here up in the balcony for mr.
Barnum's first legit show for the
highbrows stand the freaks from the show
that made Barnum famous and I can't help
but ask how the hell did those losers
get tickets oh and also shame on Barnum
and stuff I like this movie better the
first time I saw it when it was called
like jungle water for chocolate fever
elephants finally the highbrow set up
law to show Barnum produced and his face
suggests he has finally fulfilled and
yet there's still almost half a movie
left
damn it the fact that they couldn't find
a real bearded lady and that their
makeup job ends up looking like overkill
in every scene I mean she's about to
sing the film's most moving song but
George Costanza toupee look more real in
this lady's beard not gonna lie this
song is incredibly powerful probably
because it comes from the characters
that actually deserve the spotlight
also because PASOK and Paul should write
all the musicals ever from now on
wasn't she come if I asked wait is there
a ton more to your backstory sitting on
the cutting room floor because this line
kind of makes no sense unless there was
at one point a plan to make their
romance a bigger story element also I
wasn't sure you'd come if I asked is
exactly what my college girlfriend used
to chant during sex in order to get me
off honestly in the mid 1800s how much
lime green clothing was there really I
feel like she stands out here at the
theater more for this ugly dress than
for not being white mother-father this
is an wheeler
have you no shame interracial
relationships in the 1800s would have
been an interesting thing to explore but
as with everything in this film instead
of actually mining the truth and depth
of the issue this plotline is resolved
with all the complexity and weight of a
fuller house episode also his parents
just happened to be coming down the
stairs at this moment what a coincidence
and why are they leaving the theater
before the show starts Wow he changed
out of that terrible lime-green dress
into her I'm so angry I'm gonna rehearse
clothes and lightly pastime what do you
choose leave it to a white person to ask
this question who can stop me if I
decide wait let's hear those lyrics
again spoken slowly by me so who can
stop me if I decide that you're my
destiny this is a stalker song bordering
on something even more sinister who
released the weight that is pulling her
on this rope was it on a time delay also
how is this act something that can even
be practiced solo forget even the safety
element there are so many weights and
pulleys involved in this you would need
a team of people to make it happen
unless of course you were rewriting the
laws of physics along with the Stars
Cirque de foreplay
[Music]
magically appearing second rope appears
magically if I wasn't asleep already I'd
say something about the physics of that
jump and catch we just saw after all
that she still says no to her
relationship man imagine the musical
number the guy she does say yes to is
gonna get also why is the nephrons
character going on you know I thought we
just had a romantic moment with the
swinging and the dancing and the
sweating why are you leaving when we
would ever be enough for you I'm doing
this for Caroline and Helen my father
was treated like dirt I was treated like
dirt the balls on the screen movie not
only as PT Barnum no longer a racist
abusive opportunist like he was in real
life he's also worthy of pity because he
was looked down on in his youth pity the
sad white boy in 1835 America because he
didn't have enough money for his daddy
to own slaves this will be a seen these
girls watch their father go from poverty
to starting a museum to turning it into
a circus to going on tour with an opera
singer certainly this is taking a few
years at least and yet they stubbornly
refuse to age at all sneaky James Kelch
this forced love triangle is also
completely fabricated by all accounts
Jenny Lynn actually quit the tour
because she was sick of Barnum's tacky
marketing not because he didn't fall for
her bedroom eyes I've given you the
world not really you helped him make a
lot more money but he still got battles
to wage and foes to win over he bought
him a little credibility not all of it
this is like me paying my neighbor's
rent for three months and then saying
well then I've given you the world have
a not this is our town son we think you
should leave you and your freaks and
your spooks I'm legitimately confused at
this point about who the movie wants me
to think is racist and bigoted Barnum
went on tour with Jenny Lind in 1850 ten
years before Lincoln would be elected
president so at predicting the future to
Barnum's freakshow and Barnum's
historical reckoning is complete he is
now a hero who would literally run into
a burning building instead of the
shyster who would sell tickets to a fire
he started himself they survived this
unlit leash acht how much this movie
turns into a discount backdraft at the
end another critic might have even
called it the celebration of humanity
continuously callous critic considers
converting core conviction creating
confusingly quickly kowtow in character
cliche ask I would have said yes I never
minded the risk but we always did it
together
did you though you were in the dark when
he secured the loan for a business you
knew nothing about and you had no clue
when he bought the giant house you live
in when exactly did the two of you
decide to do anything together yep you
guessed it all the put-upon people he
called freaks to sell tickets
somehow collectively decided Barnum is
good and have come to revive his spirits
for one last big musical number and this
is either gonna make you cheer or else
you have a conscience and long ago
realized this movie was actually a
cautionary horror film does Barnum own
this bar why is this wall a tribute to
his accomplishments if he did on the bar
would they name it Petey's bar and num
nums he ran into a fire to save people
and now she's his girlfriend
her diary she was about how society
would react and yeah now that he's a
hero society will love him which makes
this girl a sellout I hate that idea
little-known fact in the mid-1800s
patients were encouraged to participate
in heavy kissing as part of the
rehabilitation process so if I can't let
you gamble it on me everyone was already
happy just and already no circus in
history ever had enough square footage
to allow for this fictional moment where
the ringleader a dozen dancers and to
live elephants collectively run at the
speed synchronized mechanical lighting
in the mid-1800s
well anachronism was never cease the
last two minutes of this movie mostly
comprised of after everything got worked
out circus footage can just go off and
die already this is for you hand with
the hat gift Barnum successfully passed
on his legacy of racism and opportunism
to a younger white person did theaters
then have pachyderm parking did he ride
that thing all the way from the circus
is there anything this man won't make
about himself and his own spectacle this
feels like the final shot from an
entirely different movie than the one I
just watched also she's playing a tree
at a ballet recital in the wide shot I
don't see a single other person playing
a tree
did she make her own tree costume and
sneak onstage I'll be ass for second
daughter cameo it was obvious reading
also there's a sucker born every minute
but tomato tomahto
the poor elephants of the apocalypse in
America
forming feats of only imaginable aerial
skill the flying Grayson's you something
does smell I know what it is
peanuts
[Music]
so I can say that's always yes I
don't know what you expect to find out
there Gerry you know what you want
better than me I love you mummy
you know I want you there's a monster
outside my room
naval classroom water